So, how would we use a service
to implement our application?
Fortunately, we've already done
most of the work.
We have a content provider
with a content notifier
that will notify our content observers.
Our FetchWeatherTask already runs
completely independently of our UI
Good on us.
Now we can make use
of that Intent Service
that Rato mentioned earlier.
With just a few small changes,
we can get our code working
with an Intent Service,
instead of with our
FetchWeatherTask.
To start, let's create
a new package for our service.
Then we'll add a new Java class
in that package
that extends Intents Service.
We hit Ctrl+I to once again,
add the required abstract method.
And Ctrl+O in order to add the constructor.
Since the service is
an Android component,
you guessed it, it needs
to be in the manifest.
Okay, let's do this.
Let's finish implementing
the SunshineService
and call it from ForecastFragment.
You can start a service
using an Intent
with the StartService method.
It will help to remember
how to use explicit intents.